[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to another
endgame video about six months ago i
recorded a video that was part of a
series that i started called principles
of chess end games and my idea then was
to record five or six uh videos on the
most important end game principles and
to call it a day
and i was going to do the second video
but then i had a couple of conversations
with my twitch community
and i sort of browsed uh the internet
and youtube and i kind of realized that
there is a very serious scarcity of end
game material available both in chess
literature and
on youtube in particular
now when you hear the word the words end
game literature you think of end game
instruction
what comes to mind for a lot of players
is a book like this which is uh i have
the russian version but this is
dwaretsky's end game manual perhaps the
most famous and infamous end game book
of all time
and and people think of
pages and pages of dreary analysis and
incredibly boring
technical positions and so i think this
fear this makes content creators uh and
and chess youtubers afraid of end game
videos they're very hard to make and
games are tremendously complicated but i
think we can all agree
um and as i've found beyond a shadow of
doubt and games are not only crucially
important to understand
but they're perhaps the hardest part of
the game to properly learn and i
realized that if i am to
take the the challenge
head on if i'm to take the bull by the
horns then what i should do is not five
or six videos on endgame principles but
an entire database of videos
uh not only concerned with endgame
principles but also that go through end
games type by type that discuss pawn end
games and rook end games
and all of the principles of those end
games and that discuss end game specific
themes and i realized that this project
would extend to 50 or 60 videos rather
than than five or six and so i started
procrastinating and finally
um i don't know what exactly inspired me
but i figure if i never take this
challenge on then these 50 videos will
never be created and so i decided uh to
start the end game series properly and
to continue it
uh to continue with building from the
ground up now
rather than jumping straight into the
deep end
i want to take things gradually i want
to take things slowly end games are an
incredibly vast topic i ask for your
forgiveness in advance if
um you know if the videos aren't
entirely well organized i will learn as
i go because i've barely ever made
uh end game videos but i want to start
just kind of by inspiring you i want to
start with a discussion of why it's even
worth studying end games and to do that
we have to dispel this idea that endgame
study is necessarily boring
that it's uh incredibly tedious and that
end games are inaccessible and cannot be
understood uh you know by players under
2000 or under 1500 none of those things
are true in fact i think end games not
only can be understood by
uh
intermediate players and even by
beginners but they have to be understood
learning end games will save you and
earn you tons of points but it will also
offer you a prism through which you can
view chess as a whole it will help your
middle games it will help your overall
chess understanding that has been proven
and known for many years so let's take
it on
okay let me switch scenes here
and when i say i want to start by
inspiring you rather than jumping
straight into pawn end games with which
we will begin
our end game odyssey
i would like to present
and deeply analyze
an end game from my chess career that
stuck with me
and still sticks with me to this day
it's probably one of the most
mind-boggling
and beautiful and amazing end games that
i have
ever played
um it's incredibly deep this end game in
and of itself teaches us a lot about
endgame play but the reason i want to
show you this end game is not only for
its instructive value but as a way for
us to make an inroad as a way for us to
sort of lift the proverbial champagne
glass and start
our end game journey so i'm going to
analyze the same game very deeply
there's a really cool story
um that stands behind the scene game
which i will be telling uh as we analyze
as well and i hope that this will be a
nice way to kick things off now we will
begin our end game journey with pawn and
games uh the first set of videos will be
on pawn end games and um as the videos
start and i've already have sort of an
outline we're basically going to start
by
by isolating and doing individual videos
on all of the important general themes
and then the subsequent videos will put
these themes together and examine more
complicated end games through the lens
uh and through the method that we
develop in the initial videos but all of
that will be explained and before we
delve in i just wanted to clarify that
there will be other videos on my channel
right i'll still be doing the speed on
videos i will be recording endgame
videos once every couple of days so
don't expect 50 videos to come out in
the next 50 days
but you certainly can expect there to be
less than a six-month
waiting period between between videos so
the position that you have in front of
you
um occurred in 2014 in a game that i
played with white against grand master
conrad holtz who is a fellow american
grand master now this game was played
online in a tournament called the us
chess league which is now the pro chess
league it's a team tournament that used
to be played between what still is
played between different cities
i was representing san francisco at the
time
um and we were locked in a we have a
rivalry with dallas
conrad was attending the university of
texas at dallas at the time and so this
was a very important game
i played a phenomenal opening in middle
game i sacrificed many many pieces you
can find this game online maybe i'll
even analyze it at some point and
eventually after
after 40 moves after 37 moves to be
exact the position in front of you was
reached it is white to move it is my
move
now let's look at this position for a
short while just to see if we can get
our heads around what's going on well
white is up two pawns that's the first
thing you might notice it's a rook end
game king and rook versus king and rook
um but white is up two pawns
and apart from that i also have four yes
four past pawns and the b coupon is
technically also a pass pawn now two of
them are doubled but they're connected
there's a pawn on d5 b and a pawns it
looks like it's completely winning for
way but the more i looked at this
position and i didn't have forever i had
about 20 minutes left on my clock i
started to realize well it's not that
simple
because first of all black has upon
majority on the other side of the board
and if you fall asleep well black is the
uh possibility of moving his own pawns
down the board and eventually creating a
far advanced passer of his own so
there's not a lot of time to waste
the second thing i noticed was that it's
not that easy for white to push his
pawns
if you play a4 then you blunder the
b-pawn
okay you can play b3 but where are you
going from there
and so after about two or three minutes
i identified an interesting idea i
noticed that you could play the move
rook to c4
now you give up one of your past pawns
but in return you make sure that the
others can move now you play b3
protecting the rook let's say that black
plays e4 and pushes his own bonds well
now these pawns are free to move forward
you can go a4
black can continue pushing his pawns but
black's progress is so much slower and
after b5
white is basically winning these pawns
are unstoppable in the long run
so for instance if black plays f4 these
pawns are still not that easy to push
forward if you go rook b4
um
which is by the way possible you can
prepare a5 but you have to deal with
king c5 so the winning method here is
actually to activate this rook in a very
common technique that we will talk a lot
about the rook infiltrating the enemy
territory and then attacking pawns from
behind and white is winning here you can
do some analysis on your own this is a
little bit outside the scope of what i'm
going to talk about but white is very
convincingly winning by combining the
idea of pushing pawns with the idea of
just picking off all of black's exposed
pawns and if the rook tries to help out
then of course the a pawn moved forward
moves forward
now i saw this and i
knew that it was probably winning but
after a little bit more reflection i
found a very very interesting idea that
i thought was quite a bit more
convincing now anytime you have a rook
end game
you have to
open up to the possibility of a
liquidation that is a transition to a
pawn end game and it is critically
important to always keep in mind
um
the question of who benefits in the
event of a rook trade because if it is
you then that is often the simplest way
of converting an advantage and as you
might notice there's the possibility of
forcing a transition to eponyming with
the mover c6 check and so i started to
evaluate this move well black has to has
to trade
we take on c6 okay black has to take on
c6 and i tried to wrap my head around
this position realized it was not that
easy because both sides have their
respective pawn majorities
um
and at first i i was skeptical because
the thing about this four on two right
is that black can essentially create two
past pawns on either side of the board
on either side of the king side a
situation that
that there's a name for only in russian
uh you say stanley are literally
trousers right i think it's named
because there are two pant legs
uh that are resembled by the pawns that
are moving forward so how can this
happen well let's say white
uh just dilly dallys or white pushes the
pawn what's gonna happen is this g5
white's pawns are going nowhere the
black king is gonna stop them easily
and let's just move back and forth to
illustrate this concept black goes h4
then black goes e4 then g4 black pushes
all of the pawns in order
and uh then black goes f4 and here black
is ready to create the past pawns first
black goes h3
now that pawn white can stop
but the combination of these pawns white
cannot e2 h2 and black promotes and by
the way
a detail that will be important later on
white can try to halt the progress of
black spawns with g3
here black can play h3 and it's not at
first clear how to create a second pass
pawn here the concept of the pawn
breakthrough comes to the rescue this uh
there will be a video specifically
dedicated to that concept
black plays f4 sacrificing upon this
looks like madness but hopefully you can
see the follow-up now another pawn is
sacrificed g3
clearing the way for this epon and you
get the same scenario as before these
pawns are useless they're nowhere near
promotion and black wins the game the
queen will pick up all of white's
extra pawns
so i calculated this pretty quickly and
i i realized that this was not an option
but then
right as i was about to reject this line
i spotted a very interesting idea my
idea was okay i have a move that
actually forces black to ruin his
kingside pawn structure i can make a
sacrifice of my own that brings black's
pawns closer together so that they
resemble my pawns and perhaps that will
prevent black from creating a passer
and you can pause the video try to find
the move you'll have plenty of
opportunities to do that in subsequent
videos the move that i ended up playing
is f4 i was very proud of this move and
i made it rare is the occasion when you
sacrifice anything upon end game and
hopefully you can quickly see what the
idea is now first of all black has the
movie before
but now it is no longer possible to
create a second past pawn white can play
the move g3 just to fully prevent the
progress of black spawns and technically
it is possible to create a second
password you can go
g5 and then f4 but
this is a different story because
white's pastor is now far closer to
promotion and black's passers are
nowhere near promotion and so white
makes the queen um long before black and
wins the game
now you might look at this look at this
and say well how does white actually win
the game because the white king is tied
down to the black passer on e4 and we'll
get to that in just a moment just in a
slightly different version so my
opponent ended up taking on f4
and you get after king f2
a crazy end game i mean how often does
an end game like this occur four on one
on one side and a three on zero on
another i knew this would get crazy and
i thought that i had calculated this all
the way to the win
how did i even approach the question of
how to calculate this end game well i
did something that i refer to as
long-term calculation and
later on down the line this will be a
more advanced video but we will talk
about this long-term calculation
essentially means
you act as a meteorologist you you try
to forecast what's going to happen in 10
or 15 moves without physically
calculating the moves themselves
and the way that i did this is i first
imagined that all of the pawns would be
gone from the king side imagine if all
of the pawns were gone from the king
side and white just had these three
passers this is not a conventional setup
not a pawn structure i was familiar with
rarely do you get a a double b-pawn
the question that i wanted to ask myself
if we transition to this position is
whether the pawns can
self-sufficiently promote can they
promote without the assistance of
white's king
and that question is not too hard to
answer so let's imagine that white goes
b3
it forces the black king back looks very
promising
and i don't know what to compare this
motion to i feel like it's almost like a
starfish or like a meduza moving
um in a weird kind of way after king a6
you push this pawn
and then the role of the doubled pawn is
to move forward and force the black king
back if the king takes the pawn then
white promotes okay so the black king
moves back
but now you reach a dead end if you go
a5 you give up one of your pawns
this is where you do need your king but
i figured you don't actually need your
king to help out
you just need to make a pass move with
your king
that forces the blacking back and the
entire process repeats itself again
really really cool stuff a7 a5
b6 if king b7 then just b5 accelerating
the process so king a6 b5 checking b7
you need another king move king f2
the black king has to move back keep it
going a6 gang a8 b7 king a7 b6 king b8
wait a minute
there's no checkmate a7 checked the king
takes on b7
and if you make a pass well it's
stalemate
so i figured at first what does that
mean does that mean this doesn't work
but now we have to add the pawns because
we have to see how that changes this
narrative and i all of a sudden had a
light bulb moment
okay so i went back to this position i
said okay let's think about what can
happen
let's imagine a scenario where
white can do all of that
but somehow
um
i mean somehow you're able to eliminate
all of black's pawns and you actually do
have your king
which you can use well then sorry about
that
um then also keeping an eye on keeping
an eye on levy's tournament game here
then
what can happen is well simply speaking
even if you reach this position that's
not a problem you can play a7 check
giving up the pawn and if you have the
assistance of your king you just walk
your king toward the queen side and this
is a very well known theoretical win
what you do this might not be not be
that easy if you don't know the process
because
you reach this position and if you go
king c6 it's stalemate
and if you go king d6 it's unclear how
to make progress here i would encourage
you to pause the video if you're not
familiar with the swin and try to find
uh the very pretty winning sequence i'm
gonna take a sip of coffee
okay
so the winning move is actually a8 queen
you sacrifice the second of three pawns
after king takes a8 not king c7
stalemate but king c6 diagonal
opposition very important king b8 b7 and
hopefully at this point you know the
drill king a7 king c7
king a6 and you make a queen
so
whether white is able to win is
predicated on the on the question of
whether you will have the services of
your king once your pawns reach the
seventh and sixth rank so that is the
question that i set up set out to answer
can white king and pawn little team
contain all of black's pawns put
together and this is where i started
calculating now that i have the roadmap
in mind i started calculating and at the
end of my calculation i figured yes it
is possible to stop the four pawns
and i was right except there was one
wrinkle that i failed to account for
let's take a look at what happened in
the game my opponent started with king
b5 i responded with b3 much like we
expected and of course
black starts pushing the pawns he's got
nothing else he can do and here's what i
did i made a little triangle this is a
notion known as triangulation with my
king i want king f3
now black doesn't want to move his king
back he doesn't want to allow the pawns
to progress so he goes h4
now i drop my king back to e2
conrad goes g4 and i go king f2 and this
is what i calculated too because here's
the thing
if black pushes h3
what happens well white takes it
and white easily contains these two
pawns because they're only one file
apart and the process starts to
repeat itself king has to move back you
go a4
now you already know how white wins this
so i'm going to go quickly king after
you do have waiting moves to their king
that's the critical factor here
king b7 a5 let's get to the critical
moment here
you make another waiting move with your
king blah blah blah a6 b7 king a7 b6
king b8 and here's the critical moment
now you can't exactly walk forward with
your king because black still has pawns
but what you can do is another waiting
move
black has to push one of his pawns let's
say he plays f3 you take that one
black pushes f4 you go back black pushes
h2
you take all of the pawns except one of
them you reach a situation like this
now you might say oh king g2 and that's
it we win
no no no black makes a queen and now
it's stalemate so at the very very last
second
you have to play a7 check this is a
beautiful idea king takes b7 now you
play king g2 and now black's king has
plenty of squares but the pawn is uh is
dead you're going to take the pawn and
you're going to win in exactly the way
that we discussed so this is the basic
winning mechanism or so i thought you
wait until black has only one pawn left
uh you you you play waiting moves to get
black and zug swung and when that pawn
is on the second rank that's when you
play a7 check you pick up the pawn and
you walk your king forward
and i was again really proud of finding
this i thought this was going to be a
great win
and i thought that i had it all figured
out
but let's rewind all the way back to
this position
so here's what conrad did at first i
thought he's biting the bullet he went
king c6 king b6 b5 i did the whole thing
now i make a waiting move king back to
g1 expecting h3 or f3 then conrad played
g3
and i saw this move but i didn't fully
appreciate it i thought well it's going
to lead to the same exact thing king f1
he went f3 g takes f3 this looks scary
but i thought okay my king is containing
the black pawns i still have waiting
moves we're still going according to
plan he went h3
now i pushed my f pawn up to f4 just to
eliminate this extra move
and now we start repeating the process
king v7 a5 king a7 b6 king b7 b5 king b8
a6 everything is great b7 b king g1
waiting move
king b8
and here
i saw something
and this caused immediate [ __ ] because
i was totally oblivious to this as i was
pushing my pawns i was about to play b6
right we're good black's gonna give up
one of these pawns you're gonna take the
other one you're gonna play a7 at the
right moment
well do you see what the wrinkles do you
see what i haven't hadn't properly
understood pause the video see if you
can figure it out
well the problem is that black doesn't
go g2
actually g2 is fine
but my opponent would go h2 that's the
most forcing move after king g2
black gives up the pawn
this is the scenario that we're aiming
for but the problem is that he gives up
the last pawn by force you don't have
time to play a7 you don't have time for
it
you have to if you don't take the pawn
black promotes to a queen
if you blocked upon it stalemated if you
take the pawn it's stalemate because the
f pawn is blocked and by the way if i
hadn't gone f4 then black would have
gone f4 it doesn't matter who goes f4
the point is that the f pawn will have
no more squares
so amazingly let's fast forward again
amazingly there is no way for white to
win one of the pawns and buy time to go
a7
you might say well what if we circumat
the problem by going a7 first well then
black doesn't have to give away his
pawns then we're at a standoff and
neither side can do anything
so either you allow stalemate or you
give up your b-pawn and then it's just a
positional draw
i i really
you know as i was playing i was quite
amazed at this because you rarely get a
kind of a situation like this
the game actually ended i played king g1
conrad played h2 sorry i played oh yeah
no i played king h1 here so we were
looking at b6 but i played a
meaningless waiting move king a7 b6 can
be a king g1 and the game actually ended
like this h2 checking h1
he gives up the g2 pawn first doesn't
matter which one you give up first king
takes g2
h1 queen king takes h1 and three puns up
stalemate what in a draw was declared
okay
i was really amazed at this end game i
spent a long time analyzing it and i
actually uh published this and i was
writing for chess.com at the time i was
writing weekly articles and i wrote an
article that featured this game i was
really amazed by all of these ideas and
i decided to to share this with the
world i don't remember in which article
i shared i can look i don't have this
information at the ready i think it was
an article on stalemate uh or an article
on pawn end games could have been one of
the two so i analyzed all of this and
you can probably hunt that article down
and i thought well this is a really
interesting end game
fast forward a couple of months
okay i get an email email's from my good
friend dana mckenzie dana is a national
master also lives in the bay area
and uh we're very good friends
uh he's an incredible person if you look
at look him up on google he recently
wrote a bestseller a book on science i
think it's called the science of why
he's a scientist mathematician sort of a
renaissance man he's written many books
really one of the best people that i
know and he helped me tremendously when
i was writing my first book he was my
main proof reader he proofread the
entire book he made incredible
uh edits and suggestions and uh
mastering positional chess in my second
book would not be even close to what
they are
without dana's help so we've
we correspond about certain positions he
has a great blog on chess anyways i get
an email from him okay dan mckenzie the
email subject title is your game against
holt
it says daniel i was analyzing
your i was reading your chess.com
articles looking at your game against
hold i had a question about it and that
question led me to
analyze it and i found something
incredible so in the position after rook
c60 c6
dana said that black is winning he
thought black was winning
and i was laughing you're funny dana
because
if we're talking about anybody winning
it's white and i of course checked this
with stockfish or frit i remember what i
used at the time i checked this with the
engine if you flip on the engine
and you look at it under depth 30 even
now it says that it gives like an
advantage for white again it's plus one
for white which you can interpret to
mean that white is the one pushing
but if you let the computer sit for
longer you will see that dana is right
what the heck what could it possibly be
well the amazing thing and maybe you
caught this maybe you didn't i said i
told you will lie when i was first
showing you this game and i tried to
slip this lion you know really low key
and casually the fly that i said is that
black has to take the seep on well black
doesn't have to take the c pawn but that
sounds absurd are you saying that you're
going to leave white with four connected
past pawns well that's exactly what dana
was saying remember something i said
earlier we analyzed the line where white
does not play f4 if white does not play
f4 and disconnect black's pawns or bring
black spawns closer together and black
wins so we analyzed a4
and we found that if black is able to
play g5 he wins because by the way if
you play f4 now that doesn't help black
plays gf4
and this construction is winning black
basically pushes the h pawn and then you
know the drill f3 h3 and the h and e
pawns uh tear the king apart
so dana's question was what if black
doesn't take the pawn
but instead plays the move g5
we already know that g5 is winning
without the c pawn
isn't it winning with the sea pawn and
it turns out that it is it turns out
that black's king can keep the four pass
pawns contained for long enough
for black to uh make a queen and push
his own puns let's take a look at what
that looks like and i have stockfish
open on the chest.com interface it's
still showing that white is winning and
it's giving b5 and i'll tell you the
moment at which it changes its mind at
depth 25 it was giving a win for white
so b5
okay
well um
[Music]
let's say black plays e4
and here's the problem white plays a4
white starts pushing the pawn black
doesn't even need to move his king yet
black plays the move h4 stockfish is
still giving a win for white but now
it's lowering its evaluation but still
it doesn't realize what's going on which
is truly amazing let's say that white
continues to push pawns
now here white is threatening a6 so at
this point you have to step back with
your king in order to meet a6 with king
b6 you've got the pawns completely
contained
white has no choice but to make a
waiting move with his king
but now black plays g4 and you already
know the drill this is exactly the same
mechanism
as before the engine's still not seeing
it and now it's beginning to see a depth
25 it's giving equality now it's giving
a slight advantage for black still
giving equality it says that g3
equalizes let's take a look
h3
and finally it sees that black is
winning only at this point does it see
that black is winning a6 king b6 king g1
and you know the idea f4
g takes f4 g3 f takes g3 e3
and black wins there is simply nothing
that y can do about it the added pawn on
c6 makes absolutely no difference we
already analyzed um the move f4 and we
saw that black is that black is winning
the only other move i looked at was g3
trying to slow down the pawns and black
even has time now to capture the pawn
because f4 is no longer effective f4
black plays gf and e4
so again you have nothing better to do
than to move your king up and black wins
in exactly the same way as we're already
familiar with by the way white tries g4
setting a trap right you don't take on
g4 you play h4 trousers are very
important here the quality of passpons
is so much more important
than the quantity and of bonds in
general so h4 wins and if what i
analyzed was gf and you know the drill
e3 doesn't matter where the king goes
and black wins the pawns
are unstoppable h4 king f3h3 king e3 h2
and black wins by
one tempo these pawns are not going
anywhere and when i first saw this this
blew my mind because what's so amazing
about this is how your brain
automatically takes c6 everybody i've
showed this position to all my students
even some grandmasters nobody even
thinks about not taking the pawn conrad
took it within a couple of seconds
because how can you not and yet the
beauty of this endgame is that black
wins the game
by leaving this pawn alone and focusing
on creating a passer
and it is this depth it's this just this
paradox this beauty that i think really
makes end games so rewarding to analyze
because the more you analyze them the
more you realize that yes there is the
component of end games that's boring you
have to learn theoretical position you
have to memorize stuff yes you got to do
that but that's chess but there's also
this whole other end game world which
which features incredible tactical ideas
and pawn end games are probably my
favorite in this regard as we'll start
exploring them you will see how many
incredible ideas there are even in
positions that look ridiculously simple
that's what makes chess magical you'd
have a pawn and a king for each side and
you have
unbelievable mind-boggling complications
and you have so much tactics because
the nature of pawn end games is that you
want to create past pawns and so you
will do anything to do that
and as in this position you can see that
the number of pawns often simply doesn't
matter and so this game has stayed with
me for a very long time i gotta give a
shout out to grandmaster joel benjamin
who wrote an excellent book on
liquidation in chess the transition to
pawn end games and he featured this game
this was just a year or so ago and he
actually found the win he didn't make
that mistake
so that's basically what i have for you
on the inspiration front we will look at
so many amazing end games and games
similar to this one similar in their
complexity and their depth and their
beauty we will also look at boring
positions that you have to know i will
try to cover every aspect of end games
that you have to know in order to embark
on the path
to endgame mastery and once again before
i close the video
i want to remind everybody that this is
the first time i'm trying something like
this there will be some stumbling around
some of the videos might be
um improperly structured or long-winded
but i will do my very best to be as
comprehensive as possible so we will
start with pawn end games we will
explore the basic underlying themes pawn
end games which are also the basic
underlying themes of end games as a
whole that's why it makes sense to start
with pawn end games the next video is
going to be either about pawn races uh
or about past pawns i haven't decided
yet so we'll have five or six videos on
themes for punt end games night end
games rook end games and then we'll have
a couple of videos transitioning to uh
applying those themes and understanding
end games as a whole so buckle in ladies
and gentlemen i'll be making an endgame
video once every couple of days this
will join the rotation of speedrun
videos and i will do my very very best
to fill or at least partially fill this
void in chess instructions so thank you
for watching um and i want to thank
everybody in the chess community on
reddit on my twitch for uh the
incredible feedback uh you know this
just this idea to create engine videos
is it i owe to
uh to tons of people who who provide
incredible and invaluable feedback to my
channel so thank you to all of you i
hope you enjoyed this video and prepare
for your endgame odyssey buckle in
everybody thank you for watching i'll
see you in the next video
[Music]